oh my god it smells so good
that was the thing when you were driving
down the store as a kid and you had the
windows down
it's all salt water
i'm standing on a beach at the jersey
shore looking out at the atlantic ocean
so on a typical summer day this place is
packed with people they're making sand
castles they're digging giant holes with
giant shovels and then the water the
water's packed too with surfers and
swimmers
people who seem to enjoy just get
knocked over by the waves
but there probably isn't a person on
this beach who doesn't have something
nagging at them in the back of their
mind what's swimming out there under the
weights
certainly didn't want to conceive of a
man-eating shark actually
causing this horrible death
i grew up going down the shore every
summer
it was everything
but i can still remember wading out into
that water and trying to get a certain
movie out of my mind
he was ferociously struck on the right
side he was spun around twice
taken up pulled downs kicking punching
in full view of everyone his buddy
actually saw the entire contour
of the shark
stories about sharks they're usually
terrifying right
i am richard furnikola i'm a new jersey
physician
and i have
researched the 1916 new jersey shark
attacks fairly extensively over the last
30 or more years
before 1916
the general population wasn't afraid of
sharks like people are today
sharks were considered non-threatening
if they were even considered at all
and that's essentially how people felt
about the threat from sharks to be a
rarity if not an impossibility something
of of only of only myth so much so that
the experts of the day even up until
spring of 1916 they felt that shark
attacks against a live man just simply
do not happen
but
after what happened on this shore
perceptions about sharks began to change
i consider it the titanic of shark
attack clusters and it truly did have an
impact and it was always referenced
for its uniqueness
but how do these types of stories impact
the way we view sharks and ultimately
how we work towards their conservation
the story of what happened on these
beaches and north of here in matawan
creek would find its way into our
cultural consciousness
a new folklore was born here on the
jersey shore one with sharks as the
central character
the villain to be precise
it certainly opened people's eyes up to
the fact that we do have an apex
predator more or less right on our
doorstep
i mean once sharks were typecast as
ruthless killers
it would take decades to undo the
irresistible lore surrounding their
lives and their seemingly bloodthirsty
motives and that's because everybody but
mostly the media
can't quite get away from what happened
more than a hundred years ago on this
beautiful beach
[Music]
i'm amy briggs executive editor of
natural geographic history magazine and
this is overheard
the show we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have at national
geographic
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
sorry guys
on today's episode we're looking at
shark lore to understand how it impacts
the fate of sharks that lore by the way
would include this very episode
more after the break
but before that if you like what you
hear please consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard and to ensure
we keep providing you with stories from
the edges of our big weird beautiful
world
go to nachio.com
explore more to subscribe
there's a seal
look by the shore right there oh my god
it's little head popped up there it is
in the span of just a few decades sharks
went from overlooked denizen of the
ocean completely unimportant to most
inland dwellers to global media
phenomenon
oh my god i've never seen a seal at the
jersey shore before
but after a series of shocking attacks
off the jersey shore in july 1916
sharks began to expand their territory
beyond the ocean
and into our imaginations i'm so sorry
to interrupt but oh my god
so give us a thumbnail of what was
happening in the world as the summer of
1916 starts
even though world war one was raging in
europe
america was still neutral in the
conflict and very much hoping that they
could stay out of it we were still
emerging so to speak from those innocent
years of the victorian period
where leisure time was actually becoming
more more popular and doable
and then during the summer months of
1916 the polio epidemic started to
rear its head in new york
philadelphia
new jersey as well
people were flocking down the shore
where they wore long black bathing
costumes in the sweltering heat
one of the pastimes here was something
called fanny dunking which was when
well i think you get the idea
but other people they would go swimming
in the ocean
so let's talk about the first attack the
one that's in beachhaven on charles van
sant
charles vanzant he left the other
swimmers near shore and and ventured out
beyond the breakers
the people on the boardwalk actually saw
a large dark triangular fin slicing
toward him and as he was facing sure
perhaps just touching the sand with his
feet the shark gouged out a portion of
his right upper thigh and then came back
around and clenched on uh to his inner
upper thigh area but essentially his leg
was virtually gone they got him to the
hotel manager's desk and he died by
about 6 45 that evening oh wow
so
i'm shocked hearing about it now what
was the local reaction i mean regionally
that the south jersey mayors and beach
managers they were all obviously in an
uproar it was a obviously horrifying
accident so they needed to do much work
rapidly to try to salvage the
independence day weekend
the fourth of july was a few days away
and back then just as now every day of
the summer season had to count it was so
new and so unusual that no one really
had an answer for any of it
but then
there was a second attack five days
later in spring lake north of beach
haven and not too far from where dr
furnicola and i were talking
charles brouder was a 28 year old stocky
swiss bellhop from the essex and sussex
hotel
bruder went for a swim almost every
afternoon and july 6th was no different
a woman up in the uh balcony of the
essex and sussex through her field
spectacles saw okay shark fin
dart toward brooder
turn away
turn around go back multiple times and
he shouted a shark bit me bit my legs
off they got him into the bottom of the
boat but he succumbed to shock within
minutes
so what was the reaction after the
second attack
this time it was french page news on the
new york times and other national papers
uh that a a bell boy uh lost his legs to
a shark uh on the jersey shore
and then
no one wanted to go fanny dunking or
even put their toes in the water so how
are the the sharks being characterized
now
so unfortunately the shark was
immediately painted as a devilish type
creature which was difficult to control
and which was uh
assaulting the jersey coast
but it wasn't over yet six days later on
july 12th about 30 miles north where
charles brewer was killed there were
three more attacks in one day
but this time the attacks were 11 miles
from the open ocean in madawan where an
unknown number of sharks had swum up the
brackish madawan creek
sharks had never been uh reported in the
matawan creek prior to 1916.
a group of boys were cooling off there
on that hot july day including an
eleven-year-old kid named lester
stillwell who was attacked in front of
his friends they ran to get help from a
man named stanley fisher who dove in to
find lester's body but fischer was also
attacked he looked down grabbed his
right leg and when he looked down he
purely said oh my god
fischer would die hours later but the
mayhem was not over yet
a little farther along the creek another
boy named joseph dunn was pulled under
this time his brother and two friends
went to battle against the shark
themselves
and they actually pulled the kid away
from the shark
joseph dunn lived but after five attacks
and four deaths in 12 days what happened
next would set a precedent for decades
to come
according to dr furnicola it was one of
the biggest concentrated large-scale
animal hunts in history president wilson
himself weighed in on the response
because you didn't have a singular
man-eater you had multiple man-eaters
there were rewards just like jaws being
advertised for any proven man-eater so
it ended up into an inhumane call
at the jersey shore that year the
previously harmless shark had become
something to fear
and so
they became the enemy
[Music]
but this mysterious creature about which
little was known also became the object
of our fascination
somewhere in the vast oceans beginning
more than 300 million years ago
primitive sharks first appeared
they continued to evolve when dinosaurs
ruled the earth like a lot of shark
people that are out there i have been
thinking and dreaming and basically
obsessed about sharks my entire life
you could call dr michaela thompson a
shark person but she's a lot more than
that
i am a historian and anthropologist of
science and the environment who
currently teaches in harvard's
environmental science and public policy
program
when she was a kid dr thompson was
obsessed with this one natgeo special
the one you're hearing right now called
simply the sharks she watched it on vhs
over and over and over again
the shark is seen as a living symbol of
terror
the nightmare is reenacted time and time
again
the remorseless killer
the helpless victim
[Applause]
all i can remember is that i just drove
my parents nuts because i wouldn't stop
asking to watch it
and like many people who were fascinated
by sharks part of her obsession grew out
of fear
i was afraid of sharks and in fact
memorably i went through a period of
time when i was little where i wouldn't
go in the bathtub because the sharks
were going to come up the drain
but instead of shutting her eyes she
couldn't turn away
seeing them up close through the medium
of the screen um and seeing kind of
these animals that i'd been so fixated
on made flesh you know it it ramped my
fascination with them up to a whole
nother level so this fear and
fascination were really in some ways
inextricably linked and i i just could
not leave them alone
fear and fascination that's an accurate
description of the shark frenzy that
started in 1916 and continues to this
day
but now unfortunately the strong
feelings that the non-scientific
community has about sharks could be
standing in the way of their survival
if you talk to the so-called regular joe
on the street
you say sharks are endangered they'll
say why should i care isn't that good
arms aren't bad
dr david shiffman is a marine
conservation biologist who studies
threatened shark species and how to
protect them
a major focus of his work includes
understanding what people know about
sharks and how that impacts public
attitudes towards protecting them
and it turns out that sharks are not bad
and it is bad that sharks are endangered
there's no question that sharks are in
trouble in the past 50 years shark
populations have declined by at least 71
leaving one third of sharks threatened
with extinction globally and this isn't
just bad news for sharks
predators help keep the food chain in
balance and when we're talking about
marine and coastal ecosystems the food
webs there provide billions of humans
with food and jobs
as well as recreation and cultural value
so we very very much want there to be
healthy oceans and coasts and a big part
of that is making sure that the food
chain is impact and imbalance and a big
part of that is protecting
sharks for both dr shiffman and dr
thompson looking at perceptions of
sharks and more deeply at why we fear
them reveals a lot about why sharks face
an unknown future
you know sharks have been
a part of human history human
consciousness for thousands of years you
know they're in our folklore mythology
but it's so interesting to think about
just the last hundred years or so
there's this explosion of shark lore
and fear and
what's happened to accelerate both the
interaction between sharks and humans
and this sense of
overwhelming fear so when you have the
rise of
ocean spaces as a place for leisure and
recreation suddenly there are more
people in the water and more people in
the water means that there's more of a
chance for a shark and a human to come
into violent conflict so it's really
just a numbers game
after the 1916 summer of the matawan
man-eater on the jersey shore the
seasons changed and soon so did the rest
of the world the u.s entered a world war
and then another people were preoccupied
by events unrelated to sharks
then in 1945 a navy cruiser called the
uss indianapolis was sunk by a japanese
submarine during the four days that the
survivors awaited rescue in the water as
many as 600 u.s sailors died an untold
number of them were attacked by sharks
now that story wouldn't take hold in the
public's imagination until it appeared
as a bone-chilling monologue in the film
version of jaws about 30 years later
but the u.s navy knew about it the day
they began pulling those sailors out of
the water
you have
u.s and british naval sailors basically
coming into contact with sharks because
their ships or their planes get downed
and so it suddenly becomes to some
degree a matter of military security to
make sure that
these
folks feel safe and it begins the
professionalization and the funding of
shark science
in the late 1950s and early 60s beach
culture as we know it today got underway
without the long black bathing costumes
this time around
popular movies think gidget and beach
black at bingo and the beach boys
singing about surfing brought the
public's imagination to the ocean and
soon enough the public followed
it's not that shark suddenly got like
super hungry for for people in the 1950s
but it was because people were you know
going in the water
so in 1957 and 1958 in south africa you
have something called black december
where you have a series of shark attacks
that take place
and that becomes highly publicized to
the point that um you have the the south
african government sending out you know
naval ships to bomb the sharks um
in uh 1959 in
san francisco you have a
shark attack that becomes incredibly
famous in which a young woman pulls her
friend to shore after he's bitten by a
white shark and he dies on the sand and
she baptizes him and it's very dramatic
you know she's a hero the shark is
framed as this kind of like demonic
force that she's fought against
and here we are again with the shark
cast in the role of ruthless killer
remember it had only taken about 50
years for sharks to go from harmless to
mindless murderers but soon their
maniacal reputation would be sealed in
the minds of the public and i'm not
talking about the youtube earworm that
people can't get out of their heads
about a certain
baby shark
i'm not singing it
after peter benchley sat down to write
his first novel in the early 1970s
everything changed for sharks
benchley who had been working as a
freelance journalist for national
geographic and other publications rented
an office in a furnace factory near his
home in new jersey
there he wrote a book about a great
white shark who menaced a coastal town
before it was published in 1974 he had
already sold the film rights
and a year later it became the first
blockbuster ever
the book has sold over 20 million copies
and the movie lives on as one of the top
grossing films in history
since then going in the water has never
been the same
jaws is not
the kind of stand-alone catalyst of
shark fears benchley you know is drawing
upon
trends that are happening in the decades
before it what actual 20th century shark
bite stories is he weaving into his book
there's one particular one that i think
inspires the alex kintner attack so
that's the young boy who gets pulled off
of the air mattress and so in 1958 you
have a boy in hawaii named billy weaver
who's who's similarly pulled off an air
mattress when he's out with his friends
um and killed the opening attack where
you have chrissy watkins which is
incredibly sexualized you know that
is certainly drawing i think partially
on the cochlear attack from 1959
the coglar attack was the one in san
francisco where the young woman
attempted to save but then baptized 18
year old albert cogler as he died
her name was shirley o'neill and she was
given the young american medal for
bravery by john f kennedy this story
really struck a chord around the country
dramas like these would prove to be
irresistible grist for benchley's novel
you know the initial victims of of the
shark and jaws are people that we are
primed to be upset about because they
are vulnerable it's women and children
you've got to hand it to them peter
benchley wrote a thriller and steven
spielberg made a blockbuster out of it
and after that people were afraid to go
back in the water
once jaws hits i mean
then it brings sharks the consciousness
of people who've never even thought
about them
people thought wait i've been in the
ocean or my friends and family have been
in the ocean suddenly there's something
scary in here that i haven't really
thought about before and uh jaws did
more of an effect on this because more
people saw that movie than heard about
this this real story behind it
the fear generated from the earlier
attacks was magnified through the lens
of the big screen
it definitely had an impact on me
like i think about that that opening
scene in jaws where the woman's treading
water and you're looking at her from the
bottom and her feet can't touch the
bottom
and that to me is scarier than the shark
or what might be looming the fact that
she's in water over her head you don't
know what's down there you know i don't
like to be in water over my head i'm
also very short
the impact on me was limited to my own
dark fears but the impact of the fear on
some people was to attempt to dominate
sharks
it definitely led to an uptick in sharks
being killed either because people
wanted the trophies of having shark jaws
or they just wanted to kind of have this
moment of conquering this feared sea
beast
in all of the lore created around sharks
there is something deeper that all these
stories touch upon
which is perhaps why lore is so powerful
in the first place it's our way of
trying to make sense of the world
what do you think it is about the ocean
that makes us feel so vulnerable both
you know psychically physically
it is an alien world where we are very
much not at home we are very much not
the master of that environment and i
think you know sharks both embody that
in some senses and then heighten it in
other senses the ways in which we write
and talk about that and the theories
that we come up around that
are so linked to where we see ourselves
in the kind of grand scheme of things
you know
are we comfortable thinking of ourselves
as as meat for other animals no we're
really not
no we most certainly are not comfortable
thinking of ourselves as meat
but going back to the idea of fear and
fascination that discomfort hasn't
stopped us from obsessively thinking
about it perhaps
much more than we should
case in point shark week
every summer for the past 34 years weeks
of shark shows have dominated tv the og
is shark week started by the discovery
channel back in 1988
national geographic has jumped in the
water too with its own summer shark fest
this very episode is effectively an
offshoot of this annual programming
these weeks-long events feature hours
and hours of programming dedicated to
sharks and now it lives on as a whole
new era of shark lore which reaches new
generations each year
this lore however continues to look and
feel a lot like the reactions to the
shark attacks all those years ago in the
jersey shore
it highlights the animal's power and
stokes human fears
it is the biggest stage in marine
biology
in the world millions of people will see
a scientist featured there and what
shark week chooses to focus on or not
focus on affects people's perceptions
david shiffman isn't just a shark
scientist he has also become something
of a scientist of shark week
actually let's be honest he's known as
one of the most outspoken shark week
critics around
i've been in thorne and shark week's
side for 10 years now
that's because dr schiffman studied
every episode from 32 years of the
annual event on discovery from 1988 to
2020 and why does he study it
to understand where people's attitudes
about sharks come from and how those
attitudes translate or not into advocacy
on behalf of sharks
there's i believe fewer than 10 specific
mentions of anything that anyone can
actually do ever in the 30 plus year
history of shark week
and most of those are not especially
helpful
but in case anyone is thinking it's
shark week it's meant to be entertaining
shiffman would remind us that sharks are
in trouble and stories that misrepresent
the species matter
it matters if they're wrong
it matters if wrong information is
shared because we're talking about the
conservation of ecologically important
threatened species
[Music]
since 1970 the biggest predator that
sharks face
is us
the biggest threat to sharks by far
unquestionably unequivocally is
unsustainable overfishing uh that
includes but is not limited to fishing
to supply the shark fin trade but the
problem here notably is not that we're
killing sharks is that we're killing too
many
sharks anywhere between 60 and 200
million sharks are killed each year by
even the most conservative estimate that
is devastating the shark population
which brings us back to the phrase that
dr furnicola mentioned while we were
looking out at the atlantic ocean
so it ended up into an inhumane call
inhumane call
it jumped out when he said it and it is
a consistent factor where sharks and
humans are concerned
it played out after the attacks in 1916
it played out after attacks near beaches
in the 1950s and 60s and now post jaws
well into the era of shark week we
continue to see a kind of inhumane call
on a major scale
our collective indifference is no match
for the massive overfishing that sharks
face
a reason why sharks are in such trouble
is that people don't
understand that sharks are not a huge
threat to you that people don't
understand that sharks are ecologically
important
after decades of intense attention
sharks have gained the possibly dubious
distinction of charismatic megafauna
which means that practically everyone
knows or thinks they know who and what
they are they have become complicated
celebrities and are everywhere they're
used to sell every kind of merchandise
from baby onesies to television shows
featuring cutthroat investors
sharks have become the generator of real
income for real industries and a good
number of those industries may not have
shark's best interest in mind
and now the pendulum has swung almost
too far in the other direction and you
have some people saying not only are
starks not mindless killing machines but
they're cute adorable innocent puppy
dogs and they just need love and hugs
and kisses and they literally tried to
hug and kiss while charts and some of
them have been bitten and some of the
other people in their tour groups have
been killed
there are any number of self-described
shark conservationists who attract
millions of followers on social media
by filming themselves swimming alongside
and touching great white sharks and
other shark species this is big business
and while it might call itself a
misnomer like ecotourism which would
lead to believe it's environmentally
conscientious it's more likely to be
categorized as wildlife tourism or
encounter tourism and that should raise
some alarms because it doesn't always
end well for the divers or the sharks
when you grow up watching shark week
every year you are to some degree going
to love these beasts even if they're
presented as scary in some ways it may
be even just the transgression of loving
this animal that also kills people you
know there's a middle ground here no
sharks are not mindless killing machines
but you wouldn't walk up to a grizzly
bear and give it a hug
respect wild animals that doesn't mean
fear them that doesn't mean try to wipe
them out but give them some respect
i think one of the things we need to get
away from are these binaries that we
create about sharks they're beautiful or
they're scary you know they're ferocious
or they're cuddly i think these these
narratives where we try and defang them
are just as pernicious as these
narratives in which we make them out to
be monsters
peter benchley would eventually regret
his portrayal of a rogue murderous shark
but it's impossible to untell a story
so how do we start over how do we recast
the shark and learn to tell and
interpret shark stories with their
future in mind dr thompson believes we
start by understanding what they are not
they're not our friends they're not our
enemies they're just sharks they're
living their shark lives
so sharks were not put on this planet
for our entertainment but according to
dr thompson that doesn't mean we
shouldn't learn everything we can about
each one of the more than 500 species
out there i think a really good way to
change our narratives around them would
be producing more knowledge about sharks
um more scientific knowledge about
sharks so we understand you know where
they are and what they're doing you know
and why they do what they do
so that we can
save them
david shiffman agrees and sees shark
week as a missed opportunity imagine
what truck we can do with this massive
audience of millions of people if one
percent of them really cared and really
wanted to help and shark week actually
gave them useful information it could
change the world of shark conservation
and ocean policy
there's an important if small upside to
all the negative attention that sharks
receive as stories about sharks have
steamrolled into the public
consciousness they have also reached an
extremely important subset of that
general audience future scientists
more and more we are invading the domain
of sharks
by accident and by design we are
encountering them eye to eye it's the
sharks
[Music]
with both fear and fascination the sound
of my childhood
incredible
it's even better than i remembered how
much did that influence me to know these
creatures is to go where few have gone
before to do what few have dared we
invite you to join our exploration of a
forbidden domain
the undersea world of
the sharks
the way that dr thompson's face lit up
when she saw this doc again was
priceless
her fear and fascination seemed as
palpable now as it was when she was a
kid watching it over and over and over
again now i can stop looking on ebay for
old fugitive tapes of it
believe it or not the movie jaws had a
similar impact on future marine
biologists
jaws made people terrified of sharks but
it also inspired a generation of
scientists richard dreyfuss's character
hooper was the first time a scientist
was the hero of a major blockbuster
movie partially because jaws was the
first major blockbuster movie but still
people had never seen a scientist
presented as the hero before
certainly i've heard from some of my
shark scientists that hooper was the
first time
they were aware that being somebody who
studied sharks was a thing you could do
while most of the people here on the
jersey shore aren't really aware of what
happened on this beach 106 summers ago a
good number of them still wonder what's
out there as they step into the surf
the truth is on a hot summer day these
waves are just too hard to resist
so just remember as you muster up the
courage to put your toes in
that fear and fascination you're feeling
most likely got its start right on this
beach
where people like me have been swimming
quite happily for a very long time
on the beach which is like not allowed
you can't wear shoes on the beach what
am i doing
if you like what you hear and want to
support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and consider a national geographic
subscription that's the best way to
support overheard go to nachio.com
explore more to subscribe
you'll be happy to know that sharkfest
returns july 10th on national geographic
and disney plus
dr richard furnicola's book 12 days of
terror will give you the full analysis
of the new jersey shark attacks in 1916.
you will be amazed at how much the
jersey shore has changed in 106 years
but i'm dying to know if they still had
funnel cake back then there's a lot of
information about sharks out there and
unfortunately it's not all accurate to
form a solid understanding of the
dangers that sharks face check out the
work for the international union for the
conservation of nature in particular
their shark specialist group
dr david shiffman would also deepen your
shark knowledge in his newly released
book why sharks matter from johns
hopkins press you can also follow him on
instagram and twitter under that same
title
all of this information is linked in our
show notes you can check it out in your
podcast app
this week's overheard episode was
produced by marcy thompson overheard is
produced by kyrie douglas and alana
strauss our senior producers are brian
gutierrez and jacob pinter our senior
editor is eli chen our manager of audio
is carla wills
our executive producer of audio is davar
ardalon who also edited this episode
ted woods sound designed this episode
hansdale sue composed our theme music
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
nathan lump is national geographic's
editor-in-chief
and i'm amy briggs thanks so much for
listening and see you next time
[Music]
you